[Music]
I think it's no surprise to anyone but
we have a housing crisis across Canada
you hear about it in the news Canada's
housing crisis is nearing its boiling
point rental markets are overheating in
Canada's most expensive
cities but this is what it looks like
more and more Canadians losing their
housing because of spikes in rent and
evictions it's not just in urban centers
like Toronto it's it's in Suburban areas
it's in rural areas we know that the
private Market is not providing housing
to everyone so we need alternate
Solutions now communities across the
country are uniting around a radical
idea one that upends the current system
of land ownership and who benefits from
it neighborhood groups are quietly
buying up properties and they're doing
it through the formation of of Community
Land
trusts Toronto's Kensington Market a
vibrant neighborhood known for its fresh
food vintage
stores and eclectic
[Music]
personalities it's a place with deep
immigrant roots for Jewish Portuguese
and Chinese newcomers the market has
been a lifeline and a safe
haven
but today Rising rents gentrification
and Airbnb ghost hotels threaten the
fabric of this historic
district we have seen our own neighbors
defend each other from increasingly
violent and scary evictions CH Tam is
the outgoing executive director of the
Kensington Market Community Land Trust
after years of fighting eviction
attempts a group of concerned residents
came together and posed a question
could we as a
community lead the developments and
evolution of this neighborhood we didn't
want to see other people profit from our
own
neighborhood that frustration is being
felt across the country and has sparked
a land trust Renaissance says Joshua
Bart he leads Toronto's Parkdale
Neighborhood Land Trust which formed in
2014 at that time nobody knew what a
commun land trust was in Toronto now
everyone's talking about it from
Vancouver to White Horse msca to Halifax
there are now more than 40 Community
Land trusts in Canadian cities and towns
and most started up just within the last
decade honestly we hear every week from
communities across Ontario and Canada
who reach out to us and they say we want
to do this too like co-op housing
community land trusts are nonprofit
organizations that use a shared Equity
model but unlike co-ops where each
household has a share of the building
Land Trust acquire and develop land on
behalf of a whole Community residents
who live or work in the area can be
members and maintain control through
Democratic processes like voting and
committees a land trust can own anything
important to the community often that's
affordable housing but it could also be
commercial businesses or green space
Once a community Land Trust owns a
parcel of land it remains in community
hands forever that's going to transform
the relationship of our communities to
land cuz if we can trust that we're not
going to get kicked out we're not going
to get Ren evicted we're not going to
economically displaced then we can
actually be secure members of our
communities where does the money come
from to buy these properties usually the
first place that we go looking for money
is from our community we get donations
from residents who want to support the
work we do we also get donations from
foundations who believe in our mission
when we build housing in particular we
definitely need government
investment through these fundraising
efforts the Parkdale Neighborhood Land
Trust and its charitable arm have built
an impressive housing portfolio worth
approximately $85
million it now oversees 205 rental units
across 85 properties in Toronto's West
End we're a community where 90% of
residents are renters we were concerned
that if those buildings sold to
predatory landlords or maybe investor
groups they would aggressively increase
those rents and push out lower income
households that exact situation is
playing out across the country meaning
more people are ending up on the
streets Canada is losing affordable
housing units faster than new ones are
being built to close that Gap more than
300 ,000 rental units need to be created
over the next 3 years we need to
increase the supply of housing it's that
simple Joshua agrees but says the
current system where governments
incentivize the private Market to build
affordable units can't be the only
solution you know there's a lot of
government investment right now going
into subsidizing developers to make a
portion of their units affordable what
we're seeing generally is that those
subsidies are provided and then the
developer only needs to make the units
affordable for 10 15 20 years and we
know that we actually need affordable
housing
forever parkdale's success is inspiring
a new generation of Community Land Trust
the Kensington Collective purchased this
building in 2021 for $6 million just as
longtime tenants and Shop owners were
facing
eviction Katon lives in one of the 12
residential units with dagio her pet
python hi
dagio what's happening baby snck huh I'm
not a typical Grandma I went to my first
MH pit down here in the market and how
old were you then oh in my late 40s and
they're throwing me overhead going don't
drop grandma don't drop Grandma it was
fabulous Sydney has been coming to
Kensington Market since she was 14 years
old back then you could buy live
chickens here and get bags of fruits and
vegetables for a couple of dollars the
sights sounds and smells of Toronto's
ethnic Market in the heart of the city's
Cosmopolitan downtown district add up to
a colorful visitor
[Music]
attraction the market has always drawn
crowds of Outsiders looking to
experience its artistic and Bohemian
atmosphere that Vibe is nearly gone a
along with affordable rents now Chic
restaurants craft breweries and weed
dispensaries have moved in it's really
changed a lot in the last 20 years but
especially in the last five you would
think this part of town might be cheaper
to live in it's not so it's a miracle I
got this studio what has it been like
for you to live
here knowing that you're not going to
get served in ition notice you're not
going to get an email one day that your
rent's been raised x amount let me tell
you what it was like the first 2 months
here um I talk to my pets okay and every
night I would look at my cat and go my
God I hope the real tenet doesn't come
home and put us out like I could not
believe this was mine Sydney pays just
$11,000 a month for her studio in
Kensington this unit used to go
for two and a half times as much as I'm
paying for it currently wow it's like a
dream come true for
me G and the Kensington Market Land
Trust now have their sight set on two
victorians that have come up for sale
naturally they're expensive $4 million
for the pair why these two houses
because they're classic because they
could potentially stop a broader
development play way later down the road
residents fear these two buildings could
be purchased as part of a land assembly
to eventually build a larger property
like a
condo how would that impact the fabric
of the market oh it would be so
depressing to really see that come about
you would then only have a strip of
Augusta left as the main commercial
strip so you could argue that Kensington
Market wouldn't really exists anymore
the land trust has 3 weeks to come up
with the money she is exploring all her
options government programs foundations
impact investors and bank loans and
that's on top of the normal real estate
checklist like Building
Inspections it has to be a good project
and it has to be a responsible project
because it's not just your money it's
like we're trying to Steward these
properties on behalf of the whole
Community they're not the only group up
against developers with Deep Pockets on
the outskirts of Halifax a small Nova
scoti Community is fighting to preserve
its cultural heritage as bulldozers and
new neighbors move
in the development started off small but
now they're larger some of them are
hundreds of units change is coming to
Upper Hammond's Plains in this
tight-knit but sparsely populated Nova
Scotia Community even the fog can't hide
the signs of construction along the main
road this is another another development
Curtis Wy drives around to see where new
developments are happening until
recently it was the only way he and
others who call this place home were
able to find out what's being built in
Abraham Plains it's literally been the
wild wild west of
development this area is part of Halifax
Regional municipal
which is scrambling to build more
housing it has the second lowest vacancy
rate in the country at 1% and rents have
skyrocketed upper Hammond's Plains with
its abundance of land has become a
hotbed for new housing
developments that's what led Curtis to
start a Community Land Trust in
2022 you know we want there to be
development in Upper Hammond slains but
we need the development to happen on our
terms and so that's why we taking
[Music]
control my family has been a part of
this community since its Inception so
for over 200
years Curtis is a sixth generation
African Nova scotian his ancestors were
black refugees who escaped slavery by
fighting with the British in the War of
1812 and were settled on the hilly
outskirts of
Halifax
they put us in the woods so they use the
woods uh as a way to make a living and
uh if you didn't own the mill uh most of
our parents or grandparents worked in
the
Mills Gina Jones runs the upper Hammond
Plains Development Association out of
the local community center the community
didn't even actually get a name till 130
years after it was here it was just
known as The Negro settlement
yeah I'm watching despite being part of
Nova scotia's largest municipality she
says this area has long been overlooked
and the lack of services and
infrastructure is
endemic the fight has been ever since
we've been here we fought and we still
continue to fight nobody's given us
explanation why that we had to fight for
things that uh other people got and one
of them was the water
in the mid 1970s The Province
expropriated the vast pwalk Lake
Watershed to provide clean drinking
water to Residents further south they
took the water in the Halifax but we
didn't get water in the community till
1999 and our water wasn't good we had to
take it to Supreme Court to get them to
give the residents water when the water
is coming from a lake in the community
I'm going to leave it up to you to say
why what did the loss of the lake mean
for you for the community it was big now
the kids still to this day in the
community don't have any place to go
like a beach to go swimming they're all
growing up you know what just hanging
around walking up and down the
roads roads that Resident Sabrina
Allison says are no longer safe since
the new developments
began but now people are speeding they
are flying by so fast they don't know if
a child is on the road she fought to
lower the speed limit and has even put
up her own sign but it hasn't had much
of an impact people moving into the
community don't care come out and meet
us don't drive through the community and
act as though you don't see
us Road safy is what first galvanized
people around the idea of a community
land trust the land will stay within the
black community it will start to build
black wealth over the past 5 years
developers have rushed to Upper hemond's
PLS because of the area's unique General
use zoning where apartment buildings and
large- scale businesses could be built
without any Community input there is no
signage as to who was
building um you just saw these trucks
showing
up they're
building several black families sold off
their land to developers and
left and that's when the community
members say you know this is enough
we're losing our community and there's a
history there's a history of
displacement of of African Nova scotian
communities communities yeah do you feel
like history is repeating itself here it
pops up the development is just is
growing too fast we're not gated we just
want to protect what our ancestors built
the first thing the land trust did along
with other community groups was to amend
the zoning no longer can developers
build without consulting
residents Curtis has now asked the
province of Nova Scotia to transfer five
Parcels of crown Land once owned by
black refugees to the
trust that would be an act of reparation
right because we're going to be getting
those assets hopefully at no
cost these are the lands that I'm
talking about here where we are where
we're at right now this left side is is
the crown parcel that that fronts down
onto the lake so we want to eventually
have you know beach access his long-term
vision is to build affordable housing
here for African Nova scotians something
the community desperately
needs we have all of this development
which is private development happening
on the other sides right here is going
to be this juxa position of development
and community-led ownership and
community-led development and quite
literally on opposite sides of the road
if they're successful he hopes other
black communities in Nova Scotia will
follow in their footsteps it's about
preservation right there's been a lot of
loss of land in our communi so there's
always this feeling that it could be
gone at any time so a Community Land
Trust could bring a sense of peace right
and that we don't have to worry about
that
threat back in Toronto the threat of
Redevelopment still looms over
Kensington Market the trust wasn't able
to come up with the money to purchase
and renovate the two properties it is
after all the biggest hurdle Land Trust
face it's just this massive anxiety of
not knowing not knowing who is going to
buy it not knowing if they are going to
develop a condo on it not knowing if our
neighbors are going to be evicted not
knowing if those two Legacy businesses
will be able to stay in
place but this exact scenario is going
to come up again it's going to come up
again on another corner of Kensington
Market it requires many many failures
for each one of our successes to come
through and we just have to keep on
pushing the Parkdale Neighborhood Land
trust has also had its fair share of
setbacks ultimately Joshua Barn admits
its successes have been tied to
government's willingness to help fund
Acquisitions what happens if the funding
dries up we know that there's going to
be moments where government is
interested in funding housing and other
moments when they step back the
important thing to remember is that it's
not going to disappear because we're
going to own that land and we can
continue to make sure it's affordable
permanently um the Community Land Trust
does that
beyond the goal of creating affordable
housing land trusts have given people a
voice and the potential to shape the
future of their neighborhoods I think
one of the biggest pieces of of this is
that has brought us all
together it has given us a shared vision
for the future the trust is just really
a name and and um you know an
organization on paper but it's really
mobilized us
it's very empowering when we can say we
can actually do something about this we
don't have to wait for the private
sector to solve this we can do it
[Music]
ourselves